>> TIME FOR TUCKER’S FINAL
EXAM WHERE THE NEWS
PROFESSIONALS ARE
INTERROGATED.
SEE IF THEY CAN ACTUALLY
REMEMBER THE EVENTS THEY
COVER EVERY DAY.
THIS WEEK’S FINAL EXAMINE IS
A NEW YORK SPECIAL.
WE HAVE KENNEDY, THE LAST
NONGUEST HOST IN THE
BUILDING.
AND ALSO WITH US FROM FOX
NEWS HEADLINES 24/7 CARLEY
SHIMKUS AND ACTUALLY
SPEAKING OF GUEST HOSTING,
CARLEY WILL ACTUALLY BE IN
THIS SLOT ON MONDAY NIGHT
BUT FOR SOME REASON WE’RE
GOING TO STICK HER OUTSIDE
FOR THE DURATION OF THE SHOW
AND THEN KENNEDY WILL FOLLOW
CARLEY.
SO THIS IS THE FOX NEW
YEAR’S EVE TEAM.
YOU WILL GET A HEADS UP ON
IT AND WORTH TUNING.
IN CONTESTANTS, HANDS ON
BUZZERS.
I’M GOING TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST ONE TO BUZZ IN
QUESTIONS TO
GETS TO ANSWER.
YOU SHALL ANSWER ONCE AND I
SHALL ACKNOWLEDGE YOU RULES
SET BY GAME SHOW COMMITTEE
IN GENTLEMAN N.I.E. HAVE
GENEVA.AN OUTGOING DEMOCRAT SENT
GENEVA.AN OUTGOING DEMOCRAT SENR
JUST BLASTED ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, CALLING HER A
SHINY NEW OBJECT WITH CHEAP
RHETORIC.
WHICH LAWMAKER MADE THOSE
REMARKS?
AND IT’S KENNEDY.
>> CLAIR MCCASKILL.
>> Mark: CLAIR MCCASKILL,
LET’S ROLL THAT TAPE.
>> I DON’T KNOW HER.
I’M A LITTLE CONFUSED WHY
SHE IS THE THING A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF WHAT I’M TALKING
ABOUT.
A BRIGHT AND SHINY NEW
OBJECT.
THE RHETORIC IS CHEAP.
GETTING RESULTS IS A LOT
HARDER.
>> Mark: MEOW.
MILK FOR SENATOR MCCASKILL.
>> DON’T LET THE DOOR HIT
YOU WHERE THE LORD PUT YOU
MCCASKILL.
>> Mark: FIRST PLUG TO
KENNEDY.
HEAD TO QUESTION TWO.
THIS IS CRITICAL FOR CARLEY
OTHERWISE SHE WILL BE LOSING
THAT NEW YEAR’S EVE GIG.
QUESTION TWO.
FORMER FIRST LADY MICHELLE
OBAMA IS NOW THE MOST
ADMIRED WOMAN IN ALL OF
AMERICA, THAT’S ACCORDING TO
A NEW GALLUP POLL.
BUT TO GET THERE, MICHELLE
OBAMA HAD TO PUMP ANOTHER
WOMAN HAD HAD HELD ONTO THE
TOP SPOT FOR 17 YEARS.
WHO WAS THE OTHER WOMAN?
AND IT’S KENNEDY AGAIN.
>> Kennedy: JUST A GUESS
FROM ME ANYWAY, HILLARY
CLINTON.
>> Mark: COME ON, HILLARY
CLINTON, THE MOST ADMIRED
WOMAN IN AMERICA?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
LET’S ROLL THAT TAPE.
>> MICHELLE OBAMA HAS
OVERTAKEN HILLARY CLINTON AS
THE MOST ADMIRED WOMAN IN
THE COUNTRY.
CLINTON HELD THAT TOP SPOT
ON THAT LIST FOR 17 YEARS.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT
HILLARY NOW?
>> I WANTED TO SAY OPRAH
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE THAT
TRULY IS ONE OF THE MOST
ADMIRED WOMEN IN AMERICA.
BUT I THINK HILLARY IS NOW
THIRD.
>> OPRAH IS NUMBER TWO.
IT’S A TRAGEDY FOR HILLARY.
SHE WAS ONCE THE MOST
ADMIRED WOMAN IN AMERICA.
>> I BLAME THE ARE LATVIA
BOT FARM.
>> WE ARE CLEARLY ON THAT
LIST AS WELL FOUR AND FIVE.
>> Mark: MACEDONIA FARM.
IT’S 2 TO ZIP.
COME ON, CARLEY.
YOU DON’T WANT TO BE OUTSIDE
ON NEW YEAR’S EVE.
WE WILL GIVE YOU A STUDIO IF
YOU CAN TURN THIS THING
AROUND.
>> OKAY.
>> Mark: QUESTION THREE, WE
RECENTLY TOLD YOU ABOUT A
POPULAR CALENDAR IN RUSSIA
WHICH FEATURES VARIOUS
IMAGES OF A SHIRTLESS
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT SAME CALENDAR IS NOW A
MONSTER HIT IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY AND IS OUTSELLING
ONES FEATURING PUNY HOME
ONES FEATURING PUNY
HOMEGROWN CELEBRITIES.
WHICH COUNTRY IS IT.
>> I DON’T KNOW.
>> Mark: KENNEDY CONTEND
UNITED STATES?
>> UNITED STATES?
DOESN’T SOUND LIKELY.
>> I’M BLUSHING.
FLYING OFF THE SHELVES IN
JAPAN.
OF ALL PLACES.
A CHAIN OF LIFESTYLE STORIES
INDICATE CALENDARS ARE THEIR
TOP SELLER.
>> PRESIDENT FEATURED
DIPPING INTO A HOT TUB AND
POSING WITH A FISH ROB ROB
60 YEARS OLD NOT LOOKING TOO
BAD.
CUDDLE WAG LEOPARD.
POPULARITY OF THE CALENDARS
FUELED BY A SURGE IN
SELF-PROCLAIMED PUTIN FANS.
GET THEM WHILE THEY ARE HOT,
LADIES.
PUTY.
>> Mark: NOTHING MORE A LADY
LIKES THAN BEING IN A HOT
TUB WITH A KGB TORTURER.
KENNEDY LOST ONE.
STILL EVERYTHING TO PLAY
FOR.
2-0.
>> 1-0.
>> Mark: 1-0.
>> I LOST A POINT.
I THOUGHT I KEPT AND IT KEPT
THE OTHER TWO.
MARK MARK YOU LOST
>> Mark: YOU LOST IT.
YOU ARE IN HUGE TROUBLE NOW.
CRISIS ON THE INTERNATIONAL
SPACE STATION.
SOMETHING MYSTERIOUS WAS
FOUND BY ASTRONAUTS INSIDE A
CAPSULE THAT RECENTLY DOCKED
THERE AND RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
SAY IT’S THE RESULT OF A
MAJOR BREACH.
WHAT WAS IT THEY FOUND?
A A SHARP KNIFE.
B A TINY HOLE OR, C, A JAR
OF PICKLES?
AND IT’S THE TRIGGER HAPPY
KENNEDY YET AGAIN.
>> JAR OF PICKLES.
>> Mark: JAR OF PICKLES.
>> I WAS GOING TO GO WITH A.
>> Mark: LET’S ROLL THAT
TAPE.
A MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH.
A TINY HOLE DISCOVERED IN
RUSSIAN CAPSULE THAT DOCKS
AT THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE
STATION.
AT FIRST SCIENTISTS
SUSPECTED THE HOLE WAS
CAUSED BY A METEORITE
STRIKE.
>> GOOD UNON INSTRUCTED VIEW
NOW OF THAT BLACK SPOT
THAT’S THE HOLE ON THE
EXTERNAL HULL.
>> A RUSSIAN COSMONAUT WHO
EXAMINED THE HOLE BELIEVES
IT WAS DRILLED FROM INSIDE
THE CAPSULE.
[BUZZER]
>> I’M LEARNING A LOT OPT
SHOW.
>> Mark: IF YOU ARE A
RUSSIAN COSMONAUT JUST PLUG
THAT HOLE WITH A PICTURE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN CHESTLESS IN
THE HOG TROUGH THAT WILL
TAKE CARE OF IT KENNEDY HAS
LOST ANOTHER POINT.
IT’S NOW ZERO, ZERO.
THIS IS SUDDEN DEATH.
>> THIS IS THE LOWEST
SCORING GAME.
>> Mark: LOWEST SCORE IN
THIS SHOW.
>> MAYBE WE HAVE BEEN
DIPPING INTO THE NEW YEAR’S
EVE CHAMPAGNE EARLY.
>> FIGY PUDDING THERE IS A
VIRAL VIDEO OF A COLORADO
WOMAN CHASING DOWN A THIEF
WHO HAD STOLEN HER CHRISTMAS
PACKAGES FROM HER FRONT DOOR
THERE IS A SPECIAL NAME
GIVEN TO PEOPLE WHO STEAL IN
THIS WAY IS IT A A PORCH
PIRATE.
B A PARCEL POACHER OR C A
PACKAGE SNATCHER?
AND, CARLEY, CAN WE HAVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR THIS?
CARLEY SUCCEEDED IN ACTUALLY
HITTING THE BUZZER.
DIDN’T KNOW HERS WORK.
>> IF I GET THIS RIGHT IT IS
A WIN I DO NOT DESERVE.
>> Mark: LET’S SEE?
>> I’M GOING WITH A PORCH
PIRATE.
>> Mark: PORCH PIRATE.
ROLL TAPE.
>> THE SCOURGE OF THE
HOLIDAY SEASON THOSE PESKY
PORCH PIRATES INTENT ON
RUINING CHRISTMAS.
ONE WOMAN IN LAKEWOOD,
COLORADO HAS DECIDED TO TAKE
MATTERS IN HER OWN HANDS.
>> I LOOKED AT MY RING
VIDEOS AND I SAW WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> REMEMBER NAY ABEYTA MADE
HER WAY THROUGH THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH HER
STOLEN.
>> I THOUGHT NO WAY IS THIS
HAPPENINGS TO ME.
>> GIVE IT I’M GOING TO CALL
THE POLICE.
I GOT YOU ON CAMERA.
GIVE IT TO ME NOW.
I’M TAPING YOU.
>> I DIDN’T STEAL ANYTHING.
>> YES, YOU DID I SAW YOU.
THROW IT DOWN.
>> I WOULD HAVE RAN AS MANY
MILES AS I HAD TO TO GET MY
PACKAGE.
>> GOOD FOR HER.
>> KNIGHTLY DIDN’T TALK LIKE
THAT IN PORCH PIRATES OF THE
CARIBBEAN.
THIS IS A HUMILIATION FOR
KENNEDY.
>> I DON’T DESERVE.
THIS I FEEL LIKE HILLARY
CLINTON ON ELECTION NIGHT.
MY VICTORY WAS A SURE THING,
MARK.
>> KENNEDY DID ALL THE HEAVY
LIFTING.
>> I WON THE POPULAR VOTE
HERE.
>> Mark: YOU WORN OUT YOUR
HAND HITTING THAT BUZZER.
CARLEY HITS IT ONCE AND
TAKES THE TROPHY.
>> CAN I SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH I BELIEVE THAT MUG
SHOULD GO TO KENNEDY.
>> Mark: COME ON, I CAN’T
STAND THIS GOOD
SPORTSMANSHIP.
THERE IS YOUR TUCKER CARLSON
MUG.
YOU WILL SEE THESE LADIES IN
THIS TIME ON MONDAY.
THAT’S ALL FOR THIS WEEK’S
FINAL EXAM.